[Applause]
it is what donald trump feeds on the
adoration of a crowd
and after an enforced absence he is now
back on the campaign trail
i'm feeling great i don't know about you
how is everyone feeling
good there wasn't much evidence of
social distancing in a modest crowd on
the south lawn
but most were wearing masks as they
listened to a president
who's yet to confirm he's tested
negative
the plasters on the president's hand
tell the story of his own treatment
his thanks for the prayers of supporters
or followed by a promise that the
scientists say
can't be guaranteed science medicine
will
eradicate the china virus once and for
all we'll get rid of it
all over the world you see big flare-ups
in europe
big flare-ups in canada very big
flare-up in canada you saw that today
a lot of flare-ups but uh it's going to
disappear it is disappearing and where
vaccines are going to help and the
therapeutics
are going to help a lot if it was a
rally primarily on his campaign theme of
law and order
the wisdom of hosting this event is what
will make the headlines
two weeks to the day after this one in
the rose garden
led to more than two dozen people
testing positive
what even his own government's top
scientist in a radio interview
said was predictable well i think the
the the
data speak for themselves we had a super
spreader
event in the white house and it was in a
situation
where people were crowded together and
were not wearing masks
the man who wants trump's job has
questioned the president's return to the
campaign trail
joe biden has himself tested negative
again for the virus
it's important the president make sure
two things
one that he is clear
he is not a spreader like his
like dr fauci said the super spreader
event he had for the supreme court
announcement and secondly i think it's
important that he make it clear to all
the people
that they should be socially distanced
they should be on the lawn that's fine
but in fact they should be socially
distant and wearing masks
that's the only responsible thing to do
thank you i love you too
we are now in the final stretch towards
november the 3rd
the polls show trump trailing across the
country this is the single
most important election in the history
of our country
get out and vote and i love you
whatever health questions remain donald
trump
is back where he wants to be greg milam
sky news